to the second session of the day uh
we're very delighted to have ramon van
handle from princeton university
uh who's in uh who's going to talk to us
about uh
foreign harmonic analysis on the
discrete cube so
uh rahman has asked that he
you should feel free to ask questions so
to try to
to make it easier if you want to ask a
question by voice just raise your hand
and i'll try to pass it on
all right um thanks very much nike uh
for the
uh introduction and for the invitation
um
um so uh first of all i'm going to do
exactly the opposite of talk about
fourier analysis on the disq
cube but i'm about to explain that
the other thing is that you know before
this lecture i decided to look up the
meaning of the word boot camp
so according to the dictionary at least
when i consulted the boot camp and the
town
is a military training camp for new
recruits with strict
discipline so um i i think you know i i
guess i'm in charge of the training part
and then maybe nike will
um implement a strict discipline um
so um
as nike said you know everybody should
feel free to just ask questions and
as far as i understand uh what she means
by ray's hand is
click on the button that says raise
hands not actually raise your hand
because probably nobody will see that
um so if you raise your hand then the
the nike can enable your microphone and
you can ask a question directly
or you can use the q a whatever you
prefer but i probably won't see it
um all right so let's talk about um the
discrete cube
um so uh what is a discrete cube
so it's not a very sophisticated object
here it is minus 1 1
to the n that's the discrete cube so
this is just the set of strings of
n bits um
so um i will denote my
values of my bits by minus one and one
rather than zero and one but uh
okay this is not a big deal right so um
we're looking at strings of n bits and
what we're going to look at are
functions on the discrete cube right so
for example we will look at a function
if we look at a function from -1 1 to
the n that can only take two values
such a thing is called a boolean
function
and they show up all over the place you
know in computer science you know this
is an
algorithm you stick in n bits and it
spits out one bit right or you can think
about it as an
outcome of an election i have n voters
each one of them votes republican or
democrat
and the outcome of the election is
either republican or democrat and there
is a function f that determines you know
how the uh the votes of the individual
voters are put together to determine the
outcome of the election right so this is
a
very classical application very current
right now um
but of course there's no reason to just
spit out two values you can take a
function
uh that spits out any real number right
so you just have an algorithm you put in
n bits and for every
sequence of n bits you put in it spits
out a number
so i guess this is just called a
function or
something that we will spend quite a bit
of time talking about
is a function that doesn't take values
on the rules but that takes values in
vectors right so for every sequence of n
bits
it spits out a vector in some
in some norm space so this is a vector
valued functions
um and we will have a lot more to say
about these type of functions
um and um so you know it's a very
general object
and uh we will think of um we will think
of them as being random
of the input bits
as being iid random bits
so um i'm going to think of them as
being plus or minus one with probably
one half you can of course consider
other probabilities as well but uh this
is the standard thing
right so if you think about it that way
then these are all random variables
right because i stick in a sequence of
random bits and out comes a random
outcome of this function
so um there's not much to look at right
i mean it seems like i've either
described nothing or
everything in either case it doesn't
seem what can you do with these things
but of course these things show up in uh
in all sorts of applications and
discrete probability
in theoretical computer science and in
many areas of pure mathematics
in social choice theory and uh other
places um
and they have a actually rather a
surprisingly rich theory i mean
the theory of these of these type of
functions is really quite amazing
considering that the definitions
basically uh impose nothing more or less
so um i should start by saying that i'm
hardly an expert on this theory so
um there are very good books written
about it so here are some
um very nice texts there's one by
o'donnell called the analysis of boolean
functions
there's a book by gabon steif
and i really have nothing to add to
these books okay so i'm going to try to
uh to take a little bit of a different
deck and and make some remarks that fall
a little bit outside the
the usual approach so um
let me talk a little bit about the types
of methods that have been used to study
these type of functions
um so i would say that the um
the uh the analysis of of functions on
the on on the discrete cube is sort of
overwhelmingly influenced by uh
methods of fourier analysis um
and uh sometimes uh
uh the analysis of boolean functions is
even viewed as sort of synonymous with
with with analysis for your analysis on
the boolean cube
right so the boolean cube minus one one
to the n is a group it's a very very
simple group
um and so there is a fourier transform
on this group it's a
it's a commutative group there's a
fourier transform on it and so you can
fourier transform functions
and uh uh and and you can study a lot of
these functions
by expanding them in their characters
etc and this has turned out to be
usually influential so there's many many
names associated to this
so uh one of the first ones to really
study systematically is
but then there was a
okay many many many more this is what
elite would call
the o1 sample of the uh you know the
huge number of people who have uh who
have developed this theory
um and um it has really been very very
influential and and
so much so that that often when one
starts thinking about these type of
problems one starts down by writing
immediately the
your expansion and then one starts
working with these type of things
and there are many beautiful methods of
harmonic analysis that can be used to
study this type of function
um so i deliberately do not want to talk
about this
so so so these lectures are absolutely
not about for your analysis and i'm not
going to do any food analysis whatsoever
okay so um
what i want to talk about is is is other
types of methods
um so you know there are a lot of open
problems in this theory
and uh recently a few of these open
problems uh
were solved um and uh
and in in the problems they have in mind
it turned out that free analysis exactly
the wrong way to think about these
problems
um you really should just go back to the
drawing board and
and and use uh you you know find find
different ways to think about these
these these problems
and these types of methods i think are
much less
less well appreciated so let me list a
few that i
that i particularly like roughly in a
decreasing order of sophistication
so there's a very amazing method
using non-commutative probability
um which is due to fonzwazu speak up
this is really i will have more to say
about this method later
um this is a really fascinating uh idea
that you can use um quantum methods
to study classical questions about
functions on the boolean cube
um and there there are certain
inequalities that we still don't know
how to prove in any other way
um so this is very surprising i think um
so this has been developed uh by
francois lupica
in in in a number of papers then
recently there has been a series of
papers
by byron eldaan which used to test the
calculus
which is um
which is another type of method that is
uh um
that is you know not classical in in
this type of area
um and uh last um
very recently um with uh pata vanisphili
and sasha volberg
we managed to solve some old open
problems um
in the analysis of boolean functions in
in bonus spaces
using basically nothing okay no
machinery whatsoever so let me call this
embarrassingly
uh elementary probability
so with uh
sasha with bata if any speedy
and sasha volder um
and uh you know it's sort of surprising
um
that that's you know methods that that
that are so elementary are able to solve
problems that that had been open using
using sort of sophisticated
machinery so what i would like to do
in these four lectures is i want to
mostly talk about the fourth thing
because it's very elementary and i can
very easily
introduce the basic notions and
uh and and then my hope is that i will
actually be able to prove for you
everything
okay so if full i i my aim is to give
you full proofs of everything i do from
scratch
um i don't know if we will actually
manage but but
uh but what we will see um so
let me tell you what i plan uh what i
plan to cover
um so i plan to uh to talk about
uh two very different uh recent
developments
um first one is the theory of vector
valued
of vector-valued inequalities on the
cube
which is the theory that we developed
with with bata and sasha
and a completely different topic is um
a recent result of don and renan kos
which is a solution
of a conjecture of telegram boolean
functions
which is due to um
which they solved using methods of
stochastic calculus but actually i will
give you also a very elementary proof of
this using the same techniques
okay so that is my plan for these four
lectures um
and uh uh to to show you how how one can
prove such inequalities that seem to be
outside the reach or at least as far as
we know
of of more sophisticated methods okay so
this is my plan
and um we will see how far we get
so um very good so for this lecture
i want to um uh jump straight into it
and i want to start by
by um by solving a toy problem
my problem
this is a problem that certainly doesn't
need any new ideas which is the ponca
inequality
on the discrete cube and
this inequality is probably the most
basic inequality in existence using
using fourier analysis this is a
one-line triviality okay
so i'm going to give you a much less
nice proof of this using basic
probability
um but it is an excuse for us to develop
the techniques that basically we will
use in in the remaining lectures
okay so um i want to introduce a number
of basic ideas that that
um that that we will be able to use
later to prove more sophisticated things
so let me try to um to explain what this
inequality is
um so let's take a function
on the discrete cube and for now we work
with real valued functions
um and i now need to explain to you
uh what is the notion of a derivative on
the discrete q right everybody knows
what the calculus derivative is what is
the derivative of the cube
um so i'll work with the following
notion
so if i take the derivative with respect
to the i-coordinate of the function f
of epsilon by definition
what will i do i take the function of
epsilon so this is epsilon 1
this is just a function of the input
string epsilon
minus the function where i flipped
the ith bit
and we'll divide by two divide by two is
just a normalization because
epsilon if if we take one minus minus
one you get two so you would like the
derivative of epsilon i to be one
right um so uh
this is the notion of derivative we'll
use which is just a sort of uh analog of
the classical notion of of a derivative
on rn
but unlike the classical notion of
derivative it has some
some basic properties so let's do some
some basic exercises before i start
actually using this derivative just so
we have an idea how it works
so for example um if i take the second
derivative
d i squared if
so i take the difference between the
function and when i flip
the ith bit if i do it again i just get
back to the derivative again
because you just plug it into this
definition
right i mean you should check it right
if i do it twice
i get back the same thing um so unlike
in classical calculus where the second
derivative of course is very different
than the first derivative
on the discrete cube if you know it work
with this notion of derivative at the
moment i'll show you another notion of
derivative but um
if you work of this notion of derivative
the second derivative respect to the
coordinate is just the same as the first
derivative so you should keep this in
mind
um the second thing which is easy to see
from the definition if i take derivative
with respect to
in two different directions then i can
always exchange them this
is the same as usual all right
um now
um there are different conventions for
what you define to be derivatives
in um in in boolean analysis so there's
another notion derivative that i'll
denote
partial i if which is maybe a little bit
closer to what you think of as a
calculus derivative
this what i do is i take the function
where i set the i bit to 1.
and i subtract the function where i set
the i bit
to -1
and i divide by 2.
so in d i of f i've just taken the bit
the function
of epsilon and then i've subtracted the
function where i flipped the i
bit right and this partial i of f i've
taken the function where i've set the i
bit to 1
minus the function where i set the
output to minus 1. these two things are
the same up to a sine
then d i f of epsilon
is just equal to epsilon i partial i f
of epsilon
right because if epsilon i is one
right then d i of f epsilon just has a
one in the first term and a minus one in
the second term
but if epsilon i is minus one then d i f
of epsilon has a minus one in the first
term and a one in the second term so it
just flipped right so then you multiply
it by the sign
so you can trivially go back and forth
between these two notions of derivative
i prefer the di derivative
the delta i derivative the partial i
derivative has the advantage that
partial i of f doesn't depend on epsilon
i
right so so what you can see here for
example is that d
i f of epsilon is anti-symmetric in
epsilon i right because
partial i f of epsilon doesn't depend on
epsilon i
and i multiplied by epsilon i so if i
flip the i bit of d i f of epsilon i
just might get minus the i f
so um this is a little bit boring right
now
because we're actually not actually
doing anything right but i will use
these type of computations uh
in a bit so it's good to have them out
okay
very so let me now formulate the ponca
inequality
so um here is the punker inequality
inequality
so the poincare inequality says that for
any function f
on the discrete cube
the variance of f remember we think of f
as being random right because i plug in
n id bits right
and i want to look now at this as the
output the output of this of this
function is a random variable
so what is the variance of this function
how large are the fluctuations
the pancreatic inequality says the
values of f is bounded by the
expectation
of the euclidean norm of its derivative
vector squared
so if i want to just pedally spell out
what i wrote here
i wrote here that the expectation of f
squared minus the expectation of if
squared is less or equal to the sum
i is one to n of the expectation of the
derivative in the eighth directions so
it's exactly what what you think of
so um this this inequality is is
is a is probably the most basic result
in the study of boolean functions
um it is uh one of the simplest examples
of a concentration inequality right so
the
one of the key points of this inequality
is that the constant here doesn't depend
on dimension actually the constant is
one
okay but more importantly the constant
here doesn't depend on the dimension n
on the number of bits i stick in
so um what this inequality is saying is
that for example the way you could view
it is that any
lipschitz function has um
has variance of order one independent of
the dimension right even if i take a
very very very very high dimensional
function
right if the function is sufficiently
smooth if it's leap sheets
then its probabilistic fluctuation its
variance has to be of order one
right so this is exactly a high
dimensional phenomenon of the type that
is in the title of of this series
um and um
and and this inequality plays a very
important role in improving many
different uh
improving many different things um yes
you have a couple of questions one is
what are they
is it related to the efforts time
inequality
yes and the second one
can be deduced from it trivially
the second one is is it necessary to
assume the uniform distribution of x
to make it to make this statement ah um
so the uniform distribution on x no
i mean one one can consider other
distribution of now you get a constant
which might depend for example on the
probability
p right of the bits or if you don't take
them to be independent it will have to
depend on the correlations et cetera et
cetera
so all of these things that i'm going to
discuss um
you know of course you could view them
in a much bigger framework and then you
can prove much more general results um
but i'm going to concentrate throughout
all four lectures on the situation where
all of the strings are equally likely
this is the basic case that one should
understand and after that one can hope
to
to to study more sophisticated things
but but but yes of course these type of
inequalities are very very useful in
many different settings
and particularly the punk rain equality
which is which is very simple can be uh
you know
um studied in a very very very um
general frame right so so
um this is just one very special case
all right so um good
so so this is a very basic inequality
let me give just for fun another
interpretation
so suppose that f is a boolean function
right so suppose that f is the outcome
of an election right they have n voters
they have
uh democrat or republican and the
outcome is either democrat or republican
right so f
is always takes the value is minus one
or plus one right so then what is d
i of if right what happens what it
measures is what happens when i
voter flips their vote right suppose the
iphoto flips their vote
if that affects the outcome of the
election then d
i of f will be equal to one or minus
but if that doesn't if the ice voter
flipping their vote doesn't affect the
outcome of the election then the i of f
will be equal to zero
so in this funny example this quantity
over here is nothing else than the
probability that if the i floater flips
their vote
that they will ins that they will change
the outcome of the election
that's something called the influence
and
if you have for example in the lik a
voting scheme
that um um that's the probability of
one of the two parties is the same as
the probability of the incoming bits
right it's a fair election
then the variance will be of order one
it will be one quarter and then this is
saying that the sum
of the probability that of each voter
influencing the election
is uh at least one quarter right which
means that there is at least one no
matter what the voting scheme is
there's at least one voter that has at
least probability one over the number of
voters of influencing deal of
influencing the outcome of the election
this is one of the basic results of
social choice theory actually it turns
out that this result could be much
improved and i'm not going to talk about
it but i'm just giving you different uh
interpretations of this type of
theory so i realized that in
in a lot of these lectures i'm not going
to give a lot of
motivation or applications because you
know you can find all of this in all of
these beautiful books that i that i put
on the first slide
um so i really want to emphasize
emphasize more the uh the techniques
that i'm going to be using but uh
you know it's still good to to discuss a
little bit
so um very good so let's try to prove
this inequality
um and uh where do we start
so um the very first idea i want to
introduce
is a very basic idea that we'll see in
um in a couple of in a number of
different situations
so the first idea
is something called the interpolation
method
um and let me phrase it very generally
so um
i'm going to write next to it the names
of bakri emery but
actually the same method is used in
different contexts by different people
so
i could write dot dot dot so what's the
idea we want to upper bound the variance
right what is the variance of a function
it is the expectation of f squared minus
the expectation of f
squared so the key point here is we want
to
compute we want to bound the difference
between two quantities the expectation
of f squared and the expectation of f
squared each of these quantities
themselves must might be very large
right but it can then still be true that
the difference between them is very
small right so bounding differences of
two things is always harder
than bounding just the magnitude of one
of these two terms
so how would you bound the difference
between such two terms well what you
could do is you could try to design a
function that interpolates between these
two guys
right so try to find a function
phi of some parameter t t from zero to
infinity
such that phi of 0 is the expectation of
f squared
and let's say phi of infinity if i let t
go to infinity
will be the expectation of f squared
so this function just as i increase t
it's it interpolates between the
between both sides of this inequality of
of this of this quantity that i want to
compute the difference of
right so i i design some interpolation
between the left and the right term
right so if i had such a function then
how could i express the variance of f
right well that would be phi of 0 minus
5 infinity
and then i could just apply the
fundamental theorem of calculus right
because this is minus the integral from
zero to infinity
of d dt of phi of t
dt right that's nothing else in the
fundamental theorem of calculus if i
integrate the derivative i get phi at
one endpoint minus five of the other
input so
the basic idea of interpolation is okay
you want to you want to bound the
difference between two things find some
function that interpolates between them
then apply the fundamental theorem of
calculus and then what you hope is that
this derivative of that function
is related to the quantity you want on
the right hand side of your inequality
so in our case right on the right hand
side of the inequality
we want something involving the
derivative of the function f
here we have not the derivative of f but
we have the d dt of the interpolation
but it's very natural to hope that if
you have a good interpolation then the
rate of change
of the interpolation will be related to
the rate of change of the function
itself and then you can see
why the interpolation method should
allow you to bound something like the
variance of f by a derivative right this
is a very vague idea
and we will see several different
incarnations of it okay but but this is
a basic idea
um so it's a very general mechanism and
of course the whole the the devil is in
the details of how do you actually
construct
um how do you actually construct this
interpolation
um and uh it is a classical idea of
bakri meri but
again i think you know variants of this
type of idea have existed for a long
time
that it's very natural to construct such
interpolations by a probabilistic
construction okay so let me give you a
probabilistic instruction
so um
what we're going to do is we're going to
construct this interpolation from a
random walk
the random walk will be in continuous
time okay so
so um because phi of t in order to take
the derivative has to be in continuous
time and i'll define it more precisely
in a moment
but for now let's just be vague
so let's take x t
to be a continuous time
random walk on the discrete queue
right so at time zero we start at some
initial point on the discrete cube
and then as time moves on every once in
a while we jump to some neighboring
point in the discrete tube and then we
jump to some name randomly and then we
randomly jump to some neighboring point
in the discrete cube every time we just
flip some bit
randomly and then we flip another bit
randomly and we keep doing this over and
over again right so we just take a
random walk where we keep flipping
random bits
now i will just define in a moment how
you do that in continuous time
let's introduce this object
for any function f let's denote by ptf
that's another function
this is the expectation of this function
of the location of the random walk at
time t given
that i started at time 0
at the point epsilon in the discrete
cube so this is a definition
right so for every function f we can
compute the
the expectation of of that function of
its location at time t
given that we started initially at the
point epsilon right and that defines a
new function of the initial condition
so um this object if you're used to
to it is called a markov semi group but
but actually i'm just going to do all
sorts of manual computations right so
let me make let me come to the point um
what properties does this function
satisfy right
well first of all if t is zero
right the expectation of the function of
the position at time zero
given that at time zero i'm at the point
epsilon
it's just that function at the point
epsilon that's obvious
so at time 0 p 0 of f is just f
on the other hand what happens if i let
time go to infinity
well so i started the point epsilon and
now i start doing a random walk around
the cube
now as you know intuitively right if i
start doing a random walk
in in in a finite set right it's like
the discrete cube
after a long time right the probability
of ending up at any particular point
gets more and more and more uniform
right so after a long time you go to
steady state
right where the probability of being at
every point becomes equal
right so the the random walk well the
distribution the random rock will
converge to steady state
right so if i let time go to infinity
what we expect is that
this function the expectation of f x t
as t goes to infinity should no longer
depend on where i started
right the the the random walk goes to
steady state
and as time goes to infinity this just
goes to the expectation of the function
so these are the two extremes initially
i'm at the point epsilon after a long
time i go to steady state
where um where i'm where i'm just
uniformly distributed on the discrete
cube
i'm going to give an explicit
construction where we will see that this
is true okay but i'm just giving some
intuition
so this function ptf interpolates
between f and its expectation
so if you had such a
probabilistic construction then what
could we take our function phi t to be
our function phi t we can take it to be
the expectation
of p t f squared
so if we do that then phi a zero
is just the expectation of f squared
and as time goes to infinity this will
become the expectation of
the expectation of f squared or the
expectation of f is not random so this
becomes the expectation of f
squared right and this is exactly the
interpolation that we want right so the
difference between phi zero and phi
infinity
which is the variance of f is exactly
equal to minus the integral from zero to
infinity
of d dt the expectation
of ptf squared
which is an identity so i've done
nothing else than take the interpolation
idea that i had on the previous slide
but i've executed i've created the
interpolation it's very natural to do
this using a probabilistic model of
random walk
right because a random walk will
interpolate naturally between the steady
state which is the expectation of the
function f
and the initial condition which is the
function f itself right
and that exactly allows us to go between
for example the expectation of f squared
and the expectation of f squared
and so if we have such an such a
construction right then
in some sense all we have to do is bound
the rate of change of the random walk
as a function of time and see what it is
and what i claim is that if i do this
correctly i'm indeed going to get the
puncher inequality out
okay so we're going to see that next
so these are two sort of vague basic
ideas
but these are morally speaking
these are really the only two ideas i'm
going to use in the four lectures
uh except for one more idea that we will
see in the next lecture
okay so um
good so now at this point
i have to actually start doing some
computations so i have to tell you how i
actually construct this random walk in
continuous time
um and then the rest of the story right
so
once i have constructed a random walk i
have to compute the derivative of the
expectation
that will become a matter of calculation
it's just elementary probability here
okay so let's do this exercise and see
what happens
so let me start by constructing this
random walk on the discrete cube
and again we have to do our homework a
little bit but this will pay off because
i'm going to use the same construction
it's the only construction i'm going to
use in all four lectures okay so this is
an excuse for us to just
introduce this construction in the
relevant notation
so um how do we define a random walk
let me just you know
let me just say it uh colloquially in
some sense
so this discrete cube has has n
coordinates right
the the it's minus 1 1 to the n so there
are n bits
right so what we're going to do is we're
going to wait for a random time and then
we're going to flip one of the bits
we're going to wait for random time
we're going to flip one of the bits
right so what i have to do is i have to
introduce some sort of clock
which tells me when i flip one of the
bits and then i will flip the bits
on when the clock ticks so here's how we
do it
so to each coordinate
we attach an independent
plus on process
rate one and if you don't know what this
is i'm going to give you an even more
pedestrian
uh thing in a moment i'll just draw a
picture so so don't worry about it but
um for now let's attach to each
coordinate independent for some process
rate one a possum process is just
something that ticks
every once in a while at random and
each time that the coordinate i
ticks
we sample it from
the uniform distribution
so this is the construction right so to
every coordinate we attach a random
clock
when the clock of coordinate i ticks i
just flip a coin
right and i just set the bit i to the
outcome of that coin
then the next time the clock ticks for
that coordinate i again flip a coin
and i set the bit i to the outcome of
that coin if the coordinate of another
if the clock of another coordinate ticks
then i flip a coin and i set
that guy to the outcome of the right so
if i draw a picture
um so here i'm just drawing a picture of
a poisson process
so you don't really need to know what it
is so for example here is the clock for
coordinate i
here's the clock for coordinate j these
axis denotes time
right so how does it work so for example
for coordinate i every once in a while
the clock is going to tick so at that
time a cross means that it ticks at that
time and then
maybe later the clock ticks again for
that coordinate maybe it ticks there
these are random times and the
coordinate j independently has another
has its own random clock so it might
tick here and it might click here etc
right so these crosses just denote the
random times at which these clocks for
the different coordinates click
and the definition of a poisson process
is that the times
between clicks of the clock
are exponentially distributed
with parameter one and independent
right so you just wait an exponential
amount of time you click
then you draw another exponential in a
variable that's how long you have to
wait until the next click etc
you do this independently for every
coordinate and for every um
and for every time that it clicks and
every time that for example
so at this time where coordinate j first
click you flip a coin and you just set
the value of that bit to the outcome of
the coin
then the next time that the corner j
clicks you flip a coin you set out the
corner j to the output of that coin
and when the the clock of coordinate i
clicks then you flip a coin and you set
the outcome of that
that bit to the outcome of the coin
that's it so
i hope this is clear uh what i said this
is just a very explicit way of
constructing a random walk on the on the
discrete tube in continuous
so is it okay for a question absolutely
so uh we had a question that is an
explicit construction necessary as in
are there some constructions for which
the proof
uh some constructions of the random walk
for which the proof wouldn't yield the
right inequality
i am never going to use this actual
construction this is a very good
question
um so um uh in fact i'm going to strip
this construction of all of its
interesting structure
so for example in the in in if you look
in the papers of
ronnie neldan for example then um
where he uses to cast the calculus then
he does use the actual construction
because he uses the fact that you know
exactly what the paths
of this process look like when they flip
and uh i'm not going to do this at all
i'm only introducing this as motivation
because i think it's useful to have a
picture in your head about what's going
on
you know probabilistically um but in
fact we're not going to do anything and
i could define everything just by
writing down a bunch of formulas from
the very beginning
but it's more intuitive to have a
picture in your head of what's going on
you know even if you don't use it the
picture that you have in your head can
help you prove theorems because it gives
you intuition for what's going on
but it's a very good question were there
more questions right now
i think that's it for now yeah okay so
now let's get to the point so i'm
immediately going to strip this
volvid structure okay so um
um let's compute the distribution at
time t of the random walk
so what is the probability
that the ith coordinate at time t
takes the value epsilon so epsilon is
either zero or one
okay so what's the probability that type
t the i coordinate
is equal to epsilon epsilon zero one
given that at time zero
we started with the i coordinates being
the same thing
right so what is the probability at time
t the i coordinate has the same outcome
has the same value as initial there are
only two possibilities right so
the probability that minus epsilon will
be one minus this problem
well it's basically obvious okay so
let's look so for example let's pick
this coordinate i
right so what's the probability
that at time t if we fix some time t
right what's the probability that the
clock hasn't yet ticked
right that's the probability that this
first exponential random variable
hasn't yet happened right so that's e to
the minus t
that's just the exponential distribution
so with probability e to the minus t
right the clock has never ticked on the
i-coordinate
and therefore the value currently must
be the same as its initial condition
but there's another possibility which is
that if the clock has yet if the first
clock has ticked at some point
well after the first clock ticks you
always just replace it with something
that is probability one-half one and
probability one-half minus one
and even if it clicks again and again
and again you always replace it by
something that's the probability
and one f y is one so if the first clock
hasn't ticked yet then you're the same
with probability one
but if the first clock has clicked and
you always are whatever value you have
you have it with probability one-half
so this is the probability right it's
just basic
undergraduate level probability
um so the probability that at time t
you actually you have the same value as
where you started
is this this number right which is
nothing else than 1 plus e to the minus
t over 2.
so this tells you what happens with one
bit and of course each of the bits by
construction is independent right so the
distribution of the whole vector of x t
for all of the coordinates is just
independent copies
of this of this random variable so let
me summarize what we've computed
fact
i've just proved it basically but i will
introduce some notation
so this notation i'm going to be using
in the rest of the lectures so um
let's introduce some random variables
psi i of t
which are i is 1 to n
are independent okay
random variables
with what distribution so these are
signs the probability that
um psi i t
is plus one or minus one is one
plus or minus e to the minus t over two
so psi i is plus one with probably one
plus e to minus two over
e to the one plus e to the minus t over
two and it's minus one probability one
minus e to the minus d over two
okay so this psi i t is just going to be
uh the the random variable if it's plus
one this i t
says that currently you have the same
value as the initial condition
and if i t is minus one then that says
that currently you have a different
value to the initial condition right
that's going to be the role of these
iits
and in terms of the societies we can
just express
um this pt f of epsilon right so this is
the expectation of
f of x0 given sorry this expectation of
f of x t
given x 0 equals epsilon i can just
express it as follows i take the
expectation with respect to these
c's of f of epsilon 1
c 1 t into epsilon n
which i will just denote by expectation
c of f of epsilon c t
so just to emphasize what is going on
here so when i write
expectation of a subscript c i just mean
i'm only taking the expectation with
respect to the c coordinates and the
epsilons are fixed right because this is
a function of epsilon so epsilon are
just some fixed signs right
so what did i do here if for example
epsilon one
is one right that's that means at the
time zero
the first probability one plus e to the
minus t over two right which is exactly
the psi
one t right being one right so psi 1 t
times epsilon 1 is epsilon 1 if
psi 1 t is 1 and this is minus epsilon 1
of psi 1 t is minus 1
right so this computation that i did
over here is just contained in this this
very simple notation
so i'm just using these random variables
i t
to climb what is the distribution of the
random walk and this is the only thing
we're going to use in the entire rest of
the lectures
okay so um so so if you win if you want
this random walk is just motivation
um now the nice thing is that now that
we have an explicit formula
right so here we have an explicit
formula for this object that
interpolates between ptf and f
um everything else just becomes a matter
of computation
okay so let me write down the lemma
the lemma is going to be a short laundry
list of things we can compute
and um i will compute them
in a moment and
uh but but let's just say that these
these things are just i start with this
explicit formula and i take some ddts or
i compute some things
okay and um so
so let me show that we can now complete
the proof of the poincare inequality
once we just do these explicit
computations
these are very elementary probabilistic
computations so
let's first do that so
you know i don't love these type of
lemurs because you know i'm just going
to say oh i can compute this i can
compute this
you say i will compute it in the moment
um it feels like a little bit of a
laundry list but
but actually these computations we're
just going to use them over and over
again the remaining lecture so we might
as well get them out of the way
so let's call this random walk calculus
so what properties do we have first of
all the expectation of ptf
is just going to be the expectation of f
this is called stationarity
um then remember that in order to
um to do this proof by interpolation we
have to compute ddt
of ptf right so ddt
of ptf turns out to be equal to some
operator
acting on ptf this is called the heat
equation
where this object which is called the
laplacian of f
is minus sum i is 1 to n of the i
derivative of f
this is called the laplacian on the
discrete cube now
you may be a little bit confused because
you probably think of the laplacian as
being the sum of the second derivatives
of the function f right when you when
you did
when you learned in calculus right what
the laplacian is it was sum i
d f d x d f square d squared f d x i
squared
right but remember that d i squared f is
equal to d i f
right so on the discrete cube these
things are the same
um now because of this we can solve
here we have a differential equation for
pt which we can solve so this says that
p
t is e to the t times the thousand i'll
explain in a moment what this is
which means in particular for example
that
laplacian pt is pt times the laplacian
d i p t f is p t d
i f etcetera okay so we have now some
sort of calculus we can move the
derivatives inside and outside the pt
you know this is
these type of tricks will be very useful
for us um
third what happens if we take the
expectation
so the expectation of f times the
laplacian of g
will be nothing else than minus some i
is 1 to n of the expectation of
d i f times d i g
this is nothing else than integration by
parts
if you think of the laplacian as being
the sum of the second derivatives if i
take x place of f times the second
derivative of g and i integrate by parts
i get the expectation of derivative of f
times the derivative of g
okay so that's integration by parts this
is called the semi-group property
and the fourth inequality is a very
interesting one it says what happens if
i take ptf
i take the derivative of respect to the
x coordinate
this is less or equal than e to the
minus two t
times the semi group of derivative with
respect to the i coordinate squared
so let me interpret this
so what is ptf this is the expectation
of the function f of the random walk at
time t
given at the time zero i was in some
fixed initial conditions
now if i take d i of that that means
that i am taking the derivative with
respect to the i
bit in the initial condition right so
i'm looking at what happens at time t
but now i wiggle the initial the i bit
of the initial condition and i see by
how much what
happened at time t changes right so if
we believe that after a long time this
random walk goes to steady state then
after a longer and longer time
it should be less than the the
distribution should be less and less
dependent on the initial condition
right so if i take the derivative of
respect to initial condition
this effect of changing the initial
condition after a long time should get
smaller and smaller and smaller
and that's exactly what this says right
it says that if i change if i change the
initial condition
then this changes the outcome at time t
by something like e to the minus 2t
right so this just showing that i forget
the initial condition at an exponential
rate
in some specific and again this is going
to be a computation
so let's take this for granted for now
and let's prove the punch inequality
so remember what was the variance of if
it's minus the integral from zero to
infinity of t dt
of the expectation of ptf squared
now we can just use the chain rule right
i could take ddt of ptf squared that's
two times ptf
times ddt of ptf right so this is minus
two times the integral from zero to
infinity of the expectation
of ptf times ddt of ptf
which is just a laplacian of ptf
so here we used one here we used the
first
first one was the the first equality was
the interpolation
in the second equality we just used the
chain rule and and property one
right now we're going to use property
three we're going to integrate by parts
okay so that's going to be two times the
integral from zero to infinity
of the expectation sum i the expectation
d i ptf squared
all right so here i just integrated the
laplacian by parts right i get the sum
of the derivative ptf times the
derivative of ptf which is just a
squared
and now by the forgetting of the initial
condition
this is bounded by what well this is
bounded by sum i
of the expectation of d i f
squared times the integral from zero to
infinity of two e to the minus two t dt
but that's just one and here we've
proved the punker inequality
that's so this is the proof of the
poncare inequality by using this
interpolation
and many of these these these things are
just details right the intuition is very
very very clear in some sense right i
want to to understand the difference
between the explanation of f squared and
the expectation of f squared
i interpolate between them by running a
random walk right
by running a random walk and
the key point here is that if i compute
to this part one if i compute the rate
of change of the random walk as a
function of time
that's related to the laplacian which is
something like the derivative
of the function that i'm looking at and
this is why you get the derivative on
the right-hand side of the poncarena
and and the rest of this lemma
if you will are just explicit
computations
i guess let's see no i have five minutes
i can probably do most
so um let me make a
let me make some remarks i think in some
sense this is the least intuitive part
of the four lectures
okay because um i have to introduce this
laundry list of computations
and if you're used to such things you
know like some things you get used to if
you're used to such computations
um you see them everywhere you know
these are standard computations it turns
out they hold in very very general
situations this is so called for example
a thing um the fourth condition is
called the baking recondition and it's
something that that you see in many
different places
so um if you're used to such
computations you start seeing them
everywhere and they're not funny anymore
but for now i'm just going to compute
them manually um
but i want you to think of this lemma as
a sort of calculus this is a sort of
payoff we need to do right we need to be
able to do some computations and at some
point we'll we will have to do it
but after this we can just focus on the
intuition and every additional idea that
i'm going to introduce is going to have
a very clear intuition about uh
how it works and how it relates to this
proof over here
so that's a kind of apology um
the other apology i should say is that
you know anybody who has ever seen
boolean for your analysis
will say uh that fan handle you know he
uh
i mean in boolean free analysis this the
punk rain equality is a zero line
computation okay it really is absolute
triviality all you have to do is fourier
transform what's the connection with
with fourier transform
um the fourier transform this is even
true in class in euclidean space if i
fourier transform the laplacian it
becomes diagonal it becomes
multiplication by
by x squared right and the same is true
here if i fourier transform
um this equation the laplacian becomes
diagonal and then i can compute
everything by hand um
and so um everything becomes trivial if
you do for your transfer which is of
course one of the very basic reasons why
fourier transfers are so useful in this
business
right um another way of saying that is
that the the characters of the
of the of the group minus one 1 to the n
are exactly the eigenfunctions of the
laplace
now the problem with this is that that
even though this particular inequality
becomes trivial if i fourier transform
immediately in the next lecture i'm
going to show you an extension of this
inequality to vector valued functions
and this was an open problem since 1960s
okay
to to have such an inequality and then
we have no idea how to prove such a
thing using fourier transforms
and what turns out to work is not
fourier transforms but just
just these type of very basic
probabilistic computations right so it
will pay off to have done this very
pedantic proof of a very simple
inequality because it's much easier to
extend it to other situations
a couple of questions yes so uh galina
asked uh
would uh three and four follow from one
uh
if if you take one it's the definition
um well
i mean depends on what you mean by
follow
right so three just follows from the
definition of the laplacian
um four there is many different ways of
proving it i'm going to prove it
probabilistically but you can prove
this by differentiate but but but but
it would follow from one but not
immediately you'd have to differentiate
and do some computations
okay so um but you could but
if i answer the question more generally
you could you'd never have to have a
probabilistic representation okay
at least for this proof you could use
one as the definition of ptf
and that's a very natural way of
thinking about it you just think of the
heat equation of discrete cube
who needs probability okay this is just
a differential equation right you know
uh
it existed long before probability
theory right i mean fourier
uh had the heat equation and this was
before probability basically existed
right
not on the discrete cube but but
nonetheless so
um in principle you could just work with
this so this is called semi-group uh
semigroup calculus and it's a very
useful thing to do um
but the probabilistic perspective is
going to be key for us and you will only
see that in the next lecture
okay but but for this inequality you
could use one as a definition what was
the other question
i think the uh the other question was
does this
work more generally for efferent shine
maybe in the non-boolean case
no these these uh there is a very
general theory of these things
i will give you a reference there is a
nice book by bakri
gentile
which is called uh analysis
and geometry of markov diffusion
diffusion semi groups i think
and uh it develops these type of
properties in obscene generality
okay um these are very useful properties
but they do not follow from my front
line
okay so everyone's stein is much too
simple effenstein only works when you
have
very special properties involved but
again i'm immediately going to run
outside of this theory in the next
lecture
okay so that's the reason why i set it
up probabilistically even though for the
purpose of this lecture i'm only using
these semi-group computations
i think the question was more naive i
think the question was does it work for
if you take other product distribution
can you prove the efforts time
distribution oh yes you can prove it for
stein this way very easily yes
absolutely and then what you do you can
prove it from
okay if the question is key proof of
concern this way then the answer is
absolutely yes
and here's what you do you just run the
same random walk as i did now let's
suppose you have independent coordinates
but with an arbitrary distribution
right then what you do in the random
mark you still attach a poisson clock to
every coordinate and every time it
clicks you just
sample from that distribution of that
coordinate and you replace the current
value of the sample
that defines a new semi group right
which is just like a random walk but for
more general distributions and now you
can repeat all of these things and then
you get efferent stein beautifully with
the sharp constant and everything
so indeed you can get efrenstein this
way though
uh efronstein has a very easy proof
which which doesn't require this type of
machine
but but absolutely effenstein is a
special case of this construction
right but this construction is much more
general so i hope that answered the
question
um it is what 231 so probably i'm out of
time
right at this point um
so um uh
you know what i'll just uh i'll resume
next time
and we'll take it from there so in the
beginning of the next lecture i will
prove this lemma for you which is uh
just a matter of computing some
explicit formulas and then we will move
on and do something
do something thank you
okay thank you very much rahman i think
we do have
time for uh if anyone wants to ask a
quick question
i guess the q a has been pretty active
throughout your talk so
so thank you very much and we'll resume
uh tomorrow at
9 a.m california time